you're probably pretty familiar at this
point of how to solve
two equations in two unknowns let's say
we have the equation
two x
i don't know
minus y is equal to ten
and let's say you had
x
plus 3y
is equal to 5.
there are a lot of different ways to
solve it and visually the the
representation we use in our heads is
that this represents a line and this
represents a line and if they're not
parallel to each other they're going to
intersect in a unique point and that
unique point will be the solution
that unique x and y will be the the
point where these two lines intersect
and so one way that we can solve these
is we can
multiply either of these equations by
scalars by numbers and we'd have to
multiply both sides of the equation and
then add them to the other equation so
what we could do and we do it in such a
way is that we eliminate variables
so for example if we wanted to get rid
of
let's say we wanted to get rid of the y
term so
we could
take this equation
take this equation and then add it
to what so we have a 3y here so then if
we made this into a minus 3y when you
add the 2
you would get a
you would get 0 the y's would eliminate
so let's multiply this equation well
actually let me do it this way
if you multiply this top equation by 3
you get
6x minus 3y is equal to 30 multiplied
both sides by 3.
and the bottom equation we're keeping
the same
x plus 3y is equal to 5
and then you just add the 2.
so
7x
that's 0
is equal to 35. i pick these numbers at
random but it seems that they actually
work out so we get x is equal to 5.
and then you could go back and you take
this and you could substitute it back
into either of one of these equations
so you would have let's do another first
one 2 times 5
minus y is equal to 10.
10 minus y is equal to 10
y would be equal to 10 right 10 minus 0
is a 10
and it's true here in this equation as
well so that's how you solve two
equations of two unknowns so how do you
do it with three equations
so i have here let me write it down i
pick i designed this equation so it's
actually reasonably straightforward to
solve
so minus x
plus
two y
minus z
is equal to nine
i have three
x
minus 7y
minus 2z
is equal to
minus 20
and i have
2x
plus
2y plus z
is equal to 2.
now
first of all what's the visual
representation of this and if you if you
watch the intuition when i talked about
the video on the intuition of
a three variable in equation you know
that each of these
represent a plane in three dimensions
and so if you're trying to
figure out what x y and z satisfy all
three of these equations you're
essentially saying what point in three
dimensional space
exists on all three of these planes
and that point is essentially the
intersection of these three planes and
that's very hard to draw so i won't do
it now but you might want to watch that
visual intuition in intuition video i i
did
but anyway let's go to actually solving
it so solving
three equations in three unknowns you
actually do the same thing as you did
with two equations and two unknowns it's
just a lot messier and it's just a
little bit more confusing in terms of
which variable do you need to eliminate
and when and and because of that it's
very very very important to be
systematic about it
so the way i like to do it is
i like to let's say keep and this is
actually called gaussian elimination or
gauss-jordan elimination and it's done a
little bit more formally in linear
algebra
but essentially i like to eliminate the
two x's in these two equations and then
i like to eliminate this y in this
equation so all you're left is with a z
here and then you'd have z equals
something then you could substitute into
this equation and then you could solve
for y and then you could substitute the
y and the z back into this equation and
solve for x so let's do that i know that
sounds a little daunting but i think if
we uh if we actually do the problem
it'll be a little bit more
straightforward
so before we we break into the mechanics
i want to show you something else and
this is
depending when you're doing this your
teacher might be
upset or impressed that you do this but
this is just an easier way to save time
is to
write an augmented augmented matrix that
represents
these three equations of three unknowns
and what do i mean by that
well we're going to be rewriting these
over and over again instead of
instead of writing a
you know an x a y a z and the equal sign
every time let's just write the numbers
that matter so we can represent this as
so minus x we could say this is minus 1
2
minus 1
and this is called an augmented
augmented
matrix because we'll put a 9 here so
this just says minus x plus 2y
minus z is equal to 9
and then we say 3x
minus 7y
minus
2z is equal to minus 20. i'm not doing
anything here i'm just rewriting it in a
form that has a little bit less
letters in it
and then the last equation is 2x
plus 2y
plus z is equal to 2.
so the first thing i said that i wanted
to do is i wanted to eliminate
these two
x terms right and these remember these
these just
correspond to these two terms
so how do i do that
well i'm going to keep the top equation
the same
minus x
plus 2y
minus z
is equal to minus sorry is equal to
positive 9. that's just that equation
and and remember you could write it out
you could rewrite these with x's and y's
all the time i'm just doing this for a
little bit of simplicity and you might
actually your teacher actually might do
it this way so that's that's more useful
and i like to do it this way
so how can we eliminate this 3x here or
this 3 right here
well what if
we took this equation
and added it to 3 times this equation or
another way we substituted this equation
with this equation plus three times this
equation
so what happens
so we're taking so we we take each of
these terms and add to it three times
each of these terms so three x plus
three times minus x that is equal to 0
right
i'm just multiplying this top equation
by 3 and adding it to this equation
so minus 3x plus 3x
so let me actually do it one time just
so you see what i'm doing i just
multiply this top equation by three
so you get minus three x
plus six
y
minus three z is equal to twenty seven
and i'm adding that to this so minus
three x plus three x is zero
six y minus seven y is equal to minus y
and then minus three z
minus three z plus
plus
minus 2z is equal to minus 5z
this is very computationally intensive
you can tell and then 27 plus minus 20
that's just equal to 7.
and i'm going to dwell on this step a
little bit because i really want you to
understand what i'm doing because if you
understood what i just did in this step
you'll understand the rest of this video
frankly so i just replaced this equation
which is the same thing as this equation
with
this equation plus 3 times this so i
said 3
plus 3 times negative 3 is 0. minus 7
plus 3 times 2 is minus one
minus two
plus three times minus one is minus five
minus twenty plus three times nine is
seven
hopefully that makes sense so now let's
do the same thing here let's try to
eliminate this two x
so if you want to eliminate this 2x we
could take this equation and add to it 2
times this equation
so what will happen
we'll have
2
plus 2 times -1
that's 0
two
plus two times two
well that's six
and then we have one
plus two times minus one
well that's minus one
right two times minus one is minus two
one minus two is minus one and then two
plus
two times nine so that's two plus
eighteen so that's twenty
and once again we could have we could
rewrite this you know this this equation
right here
this middle equation right here is the
same thing as minus y
minus 5 z
is equal to 7. just so you remember this
is just another representation of of
these actual linear equations i just
don't feel like writing the x y's and
z's and the equal signs
but anyway now let's see if we can
eliminate this term down here so how
could we do that well we could add this
equation we could substitute this
equation
with this equation plus 6 times this one
right because if you have this plus 6
times this you'd have 6 minus 6 and you
would get a 0 here so let's do that
so let's write the augmented matrix
we're not changing the top line so we
get minus
minus one x
plus two y minus z is equal to nine
we're actually not even changing this
equation so we're getting zero x
minus y minus
five
z is equal to seven
and now we're replacing this with this
plus six times this
so the zero the zero plus six times zero
is zero
six plus six times minus one that's six
minus six that's
zero
minus one
plus six times minus five
that's minus one minus thirty so that's
minus 31
and then we have 20
plus 6 times
7
so that's
6 times 7 is 42 so that's 62.
now we're actually almost done solving
what can we do here so i just want to
make sure you you understand our
representation what is this last
equation this you know 0 0 minus 31 line
62. well this last equation is just
minus 31z is equal to 62. and so we can
divide both sides of this equation by
-31 and we'd get z is equal to -2 but if
we were to do that using our augmented
matrix notation we would just say well
let's just divide both sides of this
bottom equation by minus 31 and we would
get
nothing have minus 1 2 minus 1
9
zero minus one minus five
seven
so we're dividing this one by
minus thirty one so it's zero zero
one minus two
and there you have it so we have at
least solved for z
right this equation is the same thing as
this one z is equal to minus 2.
now at this point what we have just done
using this augmented matrix this is
called gaussian elimination now we could
continue this and we can eliminate this
term this term and this term then it
would be called gauss jordan elimination
or we could use the fact that z is equal
to -2 and then we could substitute back
into this equation to solve for y and
then we'd have our values for y and z
and we could substitute back into this
equation and let's do it that way just
just for just for kicks
so this is this is called upper row
echelon form i always forget the
terminology but let's keep this equation
in mind and let me erase all of this so
we have some room
some room to work with
some room to work with can't do anything
without some room to work with
let me even erase this up
here and as you can tell this is very
computationally intensive and it's not
my
cup of tea it's not what i would want to
do if i had the weekend to myself
but anyway we have we've
let me write these equations in kind of
this format so we can kind of go back to
our traditional world so this equation
right here this is actually the first
the same equation we never changed it
minus x plus 2 y
minus z is equal to 9. this equation is
minus y
minus 5
z
is equal to
7 and then this equation is
z is equal to minus 2.
so this we solved for z this equation
essentially solves for z
and now we could substitute back into
this one so we have
minus y
minus
5 times z which is minus 2
is equal to 7.
so minus y
plus 10
is equal to 7
minus y is equal to minus 3
y is equal to 3.
there we have it we solved for
z and y
and now we could use substitute the y
the z into this top equation and solve
for x so what do we have and then we're
done
we're at let's see minus x
plus 2 times y so 2 times 3.
minus z minus minus two that's z
is equal to nine
so minus x
plus
six
plus
four
is equal to nine
minus x plus 10 is equal to 9
minus x is equal to minus 1 or x is
equal to 1.
so the solution oh my god my phone is
ringing so many people call me i'm going
to
i think it's my wife she might be
downstairs we're supposed to go eat out
but anyway let me just finish this so
the solution to this three by three
equation is the point x is equal to one
y is equal to three
and z is equal to minus two and that's
that you that's the unique point in
three-dimensional space that lies on all
three of these planes or the unique
point where these three planes intersect
anyway i hope you got that it's time for
me to go have dinner with my wife see
you soon